¿Te da pereza cepillarte los dientes?
Pues atento a esto. Un niño cepillándole
los dientes a un caimán.
El día de hoy vamos a cepillarle los
dientes a Rique.
Amiguitos, ven rápido. Ya me estoy
desesperando ya.
Emir, ¿y tú qué haces ahí, Emir?
Pillándole los dientes a mi amigo.
A tu amigo.
Sí.
Ah, tú si quieres a tu amiguito.
Oye, Miri, ¿y por qué no me lo cepilles
a mí? Ah,
¿por qué no me lo cepilles a mí?
No, porque esto es mío.
Ah, ese es tuyo. Es
de mi amigo.
Ah, o sea, que tú le compras el
colgatico a tu amigo.
Sí, pues te puedes ir ya. Este vídeo se
ha hecho viral hoy. Mientras tú te
quejas porque te sangran la sencilla si
tienes mal aliento, este chaval está
aquí metiéndole el cepillo a un
depredador con 80 dientes. Si cierta
marca famosa con cierto reptil en el
logo y otra de cepillos dentales no está
patrocinando esto, han perdido una
oportunidad histórica. Porque claro,
nosotros siempre decimos, "Cepíllate al
menos dos veces al día, usa hilo,
revisiones." Pero nadie nos había
preparado para esto. Eso sí, hay una
cosa que este vídeo demuestra mejor que
cualquier campaña de salud, que la boca
importa, incluso si mide 1 metro y puede
arrancarte la mano. Así que la próxima
vez que te dé pereza cepillarte,
acuérdate de este niño, porque si él
puede con un caimán, tú también puedes
con tus dientes.